yeah this is like the build up since I
think episode one that's uh people have
been asking for you to go really yeah
yeah like you're the goat so everyone's
always like oh okay okay now you guys
are hyping me up right away I appreciate
it such a great guy people just love you
on your own marriage yeah but thank you
very much for coming on and uh I guess
this is a late welcome to Japan because
you've been here for like over like a
how long you been here now like a month
yeah we we left when you got here yeah
yeah it was so fun like uh I was so
excited to finally come and try and save
me meet you guys and then uh you guys
just to go
we heard you were coming we heard you
were coming we were like no I don't want
to [ __ ] with this guy there's so much
time to not go anywhere
yeah yeah like how how's your Japan
experience been so far right again
pretty good having uh having a lot of
fun you're basically retired at this
point I feel like that's what I want to
say you're just like enjoying your
retirement in Japan now yeah well we
have a lot of you know chill to catch up
with yeah I feel like I'm doing more
stuff here than I've done like the last
three years in UK right well there's not
much to do yeah
if you don't drink in pubs there's
really the options are limited and even
if you do drink in pubs it's just like
how many times a week I'm not drink in a
pub and do something new you know it's
let's go to the next Pub yeah to be very
even Japanese people are like you're
doing more stuff than I've done for
whilst because they're working all day
yeah
I have to do this thing called work well
that's why I'm moving to Japan right as
a YouTuber it's like it's great you get
like The Best of Both Worlds you get to
enjoy the really cool Parts about Japan
without having to partake in the normal
uh work culture man life which is not
horriously one of the worst in the world
yeah it's really bad were you always uh
did you always have like a fascination
with Japan I can't remember if you did
or no that's kind of like you came here
once and you were like yeah yeah it was
uh my wife Mary wanted to go and I was
like sure whatever and then
I've always been into anime but I never
had like a big obsession with Japan
right yeah yeah I feel it's just you're
probably just like we're you know
exposed to a lot of Japanese like
culture right like you know like
obviously the anime but also like just
the games and stuff like that so I feel
you kind of just like yeah like everyone
kind of yeah that's why there's a lot of
curiosity yeah definitely definitely was
that a point where you came to Japan
you're like [ __ ] I can see myself yeah
what was the Turning Point yeah that was
actually four years ago something like
that we were here for a month and yeah
after that we were like damn we really
don't want to go home this is actually
really good was that the trip I
mitchelled
we used to come here every year and yeah
yeah we had that we stayed a little
longer like a month and then we were
just like damn it's actually really nice
so we had a meeting with people I'm like
oh how's the Visa gonna go and like they
were like like a couple months and then
we're good we're like okay great so we
were planning our wedding at the same
time yeah and we were like okay let's
keep we're gonna make this work we're
gonna do it as fast as possible and then
yeah obviously Kobe hit in two years I
think three years so we're used to close
to three years yeah it was pretty brutal
yeah yeah it was not fun
but now I'm here yeah
and no one else can understand I was
gonna say honestly everyone pretty
thought that you just like did it on a
whim I feel like in someone said YouTube
what does he get to go in I I've been
trying to go in for the past two years
uh maybe I don't know like
it took a long time but we didn't really
talk about it yeah I was so [ __ ]
pissed off having to wait too and I was
just so mad but I was trying to hold it
in because I didn't want to be entitled
about entering the country but it was
yeah it was rough yeah because people
are very picky about it and they're
really like yeah oh yeah you have to
deserve to come to you yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you can't just like anime and play
Nintendo you don't really enjoy that's
the problem if you do only like anime
and you want to go to Japan
with tourists to go to Japan we don't
warn you here yeah well because the
thing is like you were waiting for two
years to come in Japan I think we were
wasting two years to leave
first opportunity we're like all right
yeah but like now that we're now that
we're back like I've really really
missed a lot of like little things in
Japan
traveling out there I can't imagine how
it's been for you just like experiencing
just living here for the first time for
the first four months has there been
like any like different different like
little things that you've noticed living
here
that you've really enjoyed and maybe
some things that you haven't uh and
there's a lot of [ __ ] paperwork
first time
someone understands the pain yeah but we
got a taste of that before obviously
yeah Visa you kind of realize Jesus
Christ I had to resubmit it three times
as well because it kept expiring and so
it's like redo all the papers and yeah
but even like getting uh Edgar for
salads oh my [ __ ] god that sounded
like worse than getting you over
I mean you have to ran out of [ __ ]
private jet for that yeah we did get it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's a real
Alpha move yeah
I I actually we we thought about it
quite early like okay how can we make
this easier to bring our dogs over
because it was such a hassle yeah and
then Martin proposed like getting a
private time I was like no [ __ ] way
I'm paying man why would I ever do that
that's so stupid but then the whole
process is so complicated and it might
not make something easy yeah my dog was
one kilo over overweight for all the
airlines in the entire world like it's
where I've called every Airline ever oh
no there's one airline that was like
it's okay but if uh people have a falcon
on board then you can't go
a falcon yeah something like uh Eastern
countries they prioritize Falcons on the
watch
like what are these roles
we go by the the predator
screws on top gets first here do you
know how it is I mean you know you put
them in a pen we'll see what happens
if there's two chickens we gotta find a
flight
I'm not rolling the dice on the Falcon I
like how they're just like Falcon's
pretty sick though
like I was specifically a falcon yeah
out of everything no other Predator how
many people are transporting Falcons out
there in the world they have a lot of
Falcons but uh yeah it's um we didn't
risk that and then yeah my dog was one
killer too too fat and we had already
dieted him once it was really Slim and
ready for the flight but then obviously
everything got delayed was was there a
part of you that didn't want to tell
YouTube that you got a private jet
because you didn't want to deal with
people being like wow
yes well because people I feel so a
little bit weird about that you know
being like oh he's just trying to [ __ ]
it's like it's like how much do you have
to pretend like you don't have money
you know what I mean I just don't like
the whole like for the environmental
reasons I guess that felt a little bit
shitty but like we had a decent I mean
you're not Elon Musk taking a nine
minute chat ride so I feel like that's
you know you took one of the longest
possible rides you could have I'm not
trying to justify it for you it was a
good purchase investment quite frankly I
mean yeah it was pretty cool
I would do exactly the same dogs
they're basically a children yeah I do
it for my kids
yeah I wouldn't do it for my kids really
doctor maybe yeah
I would say I would do it for my kids
but actually it would just be for me
yeah sure yeah the tier list goes Falcon
dog
hits are so prioritized you wouldn't
wait like the dog has to weigh a certain
amount of kilos yeah my dog was too fat
that's why we had to take the kids the
kid couldn't but you know
you're like hold up how much is that
child weigh
so why the dollars yeah it is weird yeah
oh yeah I never thought about it like
that because I've never had to transport
animals uh thank
no kids
please
prefer to see it next to a dime I would
100
if that was an option in my flight I
would take that every time crying baby
versus dog of course of course I'm gonna
pick the dog every time you know
definitely very true very true I mean
I'm sure we have all had enough
experience with flights where there's
just that one kid that just oh my God
explained the kid though I'm like ah the
you know it's like the kid decided you
know what I'm gonna [ __ ] with everyone
today I'm gonna cry they do though I'm
like
I'm like we're out of a jurisdiction
right I can get away with it
we have our international waters yeah
yeah well like the babies I can
understand because you know no they
can't control but sometimes when they
there are some kids that are like three
or four and their parents just like let
them do whatever they oh my God that's
the ones that really like grind my gears
you know I don't think kids should be in
business class I don't think they've
earned it you know I just don't who if I
say kids in business
I went on the business class and there's
two kids had their own seat and I'm like
you mother yeah
even if I was a billionaire I'm putting
my kid in the worst economy seat the
police right here he's not going to
appreciate the business
I just I just
just not going to appreciate it no no
why would you I don't care how rich you
are well either that or the kid's gonna
get used to it wow you got the sh do you
got the small seats like a [ __ ]
peasant but when you're a kid just going
on a flight it's fun enough yeah like
did you just give that kid a Game Boy oh
so wow that's not appropriate for the
times
anything that runs Minecraft and he'll
be fine yeah sure sure yeah because
we're getting to the points now where
Wi-Fi is starting to be used on flights
and to me that's so alien and I don't
like it I like being it's also [ __ ] huh
yeah
it is [ __ ] I think we'll get to the
point where it's gonna get become yeah
you're right become usable Extreme
videos and at that point I'm like I kind
of like going on a flight and just
feeling like you're completely
disconnected and I'm gonna be that old
guy who is like all things were better
when you're gonna use internet yeah also
remember downloading the entire library
of Netflix on my phone so I can not
watch it I feel like there's like gonna
be some level of like Nostalgia to it as
well because it's a very like novel
thing where it's like you know like the
airplane moving experience it's like you
know we're going to be there Generations
like back in our day so we had to look
at adjacency film for this small
do you guys remember when they changed
the rules so that you can finally
[ __ ] use your or whatever electronic
device
because you have to you have to tone it
off when did they change it when
airplane mode was invented on like no no
it was not that long ago really yeah
pretty recently yeah and it was like the
greatest change of all time because
every time why do I have to put it away
yeah or even some like flights they
still like make you put it away or they
still announce that you're not allowed
to use it what the [ __ ] how dare they
yeah and then nobody just listens
basically yeah like they're like I'd be
on my phone and then like a student is
walking up to me and be like oh excuse
me you have to take you have to put that
hasn't happened to me like it happened
to me once she was like you have to put
your phone I still do that and I was
like oh okay and I put in my pocket she
walked off
as anyone would do yeah
what a terrorist Jesus Christ
because I'm walking around and no one's
following it everyone's doing the exact
same thing because it's like it's what
other people do you think it's okay yeah
did you have the thing where like
recently I think some of the planes to
have it so that when you if you leave
your mobile data on or something like
the the phone knows somehow that you're
on a plane and it turns into like plain
something oh it's okay to some data but
it's like the plane it's really weird I
don't know what this is I've never used
I'm never gonna make a call yeah I do
not want to make a call on a flight yeah
I'm not that much of a businessman no no
I don't know too lazy would you say then
you're still like on your honeymoon
phase in Japan or is the reality kind of
slowly starting to sing in the reality
what is the reality the reality holes
like Japan is cool but it's not like
it's always me yeah you have to Surf
every week
uh yeah I mean we kept thinking it would
I think we actually had a different
sorry to experience with the first month
we were like oh [ __ ] we actually like
reset everything yeah and now we kind of
have a lot of [ __ ] to do to
kind of get there's always something
yeah and there was a lot and we kind of
It kind of stressed me out a bit I was
like oh damn that's actually not like
it's not food it's not just like a
roller coaster right away yeah yeah I
think uh we just settle in more and more
and more and now we've been here four
months so we're still really really
enjoy it yeah it's really fun that's
good but I do think I mean obviously
like yeah I don't know because I because
I remember the when when you finally
announced that you were gonna you and
Marty were gonna be moving here yeah and
just like on on your videos just the
amount of comments you probably got of
like well Japan's not that great of a
country do you know all of these
statistics
weird about Japan yeah yeah they're
really weird and it's like only Japan I
feel because like if you were like oh
I'm moving to you know the UK people
won't be like well did you know all
these stats in the UK it's like why is
it only Japan that is like put up on
this like golden platform of Standards
people either idolize it or they hate it
yeah there's no in between yeah that's
true yeah it does feel like especially
on the internet I don't know if it's
just on the Internet or with like
everyone but people like Japan has like
this really weird image of just being
like things that come from Japan are
very like I think is that Meme of that
guy being like thing thing from Japan
yeah but like yeah it's pretty [ __ ]
right I mean
there are a lot of things you're like
actually this is pretty [ __ ] sick and
other times you're like yeah it's
liberated I I don't know like when you
see videos of like did you guys know
they still use fax machines it's like
all right okay all right thanks for that
I mean yeah cool I get it not gonna make
my life easier yeah